so from your two prior films Redemption
and the wait can you tell us about the
coverage and getting your shots and we
do you tend to get shots in just one or
two takes or what's your style well it
depends on the situation but with the
weight that was that was a real learner
because that's the real story was the
weight because you want to see a classic
amateur starting out as an amateur and
then you know my good friend Pete Kalani
and the DP he's gonna be the DP on amber
as well he turned around and said Chris
when you started this it was two days
now he's thinking you started this you
were about as wrong as an amateur could
get but he was just like now you're
about as close you get real close to
professional and he was just like I saw
you grow in two days and you know
Sisseton you know we've been adding a
lot but one of the biggest things that I
learned in the in shooting the weight
was you have to be able to shoot
sections at a time like if I really
learned about lighting and how long it
takes to properly light is set in order
to shoot you know I'm planning to shoot
oh yeah I'll shoot this section and
shoot this I was gonna actually try to
shoot the short film linearly like he
does this then he walks over to here and
he does this and he turns around in the
room and he walks over and he does this
and this and the crew just and it was
just like I didn't understand why and
then after the first time that we did a
sense of what's up for 45 minutes just
to light that long shot and they notice
is that okay now we're gonna do this
shot we just took another 45 minutes to
breathe strike everything and move all
the lights and then now do this side of
the room and then I kind of did that two
times and then I said everybody stop
we got the shot and I said don't do
anything outside a half-hour out and I
redirected everything today we were
shooting situationally you shoot one
wall first and then everything happens
it didn't luckily the weight was in one
room so it was easy for me to learn this
you shoot one wall first do all the
coverage you need for that one wall go
to the next wall now you do all the
coverage you need for that one and that
way you can get the most with your
lighting setups without striking and
after we set up and strike and we set up
and that would have killed the shoot we
would have never
in a project done in two days it would
have never happened I think that was the
biggest thing I learned right out of the
gate as a filmmaker because I
immediately saw if we go at this pace we
won't even get halfway through with one
day and you know I'd shoot in two day
you know burst so that was the biggest
thing that I learned what are some of
the non-technical things that you've
noticed that professionals do I know you
said being detail-oriented is very
important to you what are some of the
things you've picked up on it you see
that that's not untechnical as a
director
the one thing I'm learning is subtleties
as how to communicate with the actor I
don't think there's any set way to do
that because every person is different
everybody's going to resonate to you
know so that's use something that you
say differently so I think the main
thing for that was a relating with my
actors and I think that was the biggest
thing and I learned a lot even working
with angel because I understood angel
well you know it uh you know starting
out he's performing it in a certain way
but I see the character expressing
himself in a different way but I you
know you I don't think you should tell
an actor how to perform as a director I
should just implant the seed the emotion
so that they can find the choices that
lead them to where I want them to be and
then they feel like they've organically
ended at the same place where now that's
where I wanted you to be so it was it
was a to me that's the nesting
intangible and in filmmaking to me it's
like you can be is up there's books and
textbooks for a lot of things and stuff
like that but I don't think there's a
textbook for how to you know relate with
your actors that's something that you
know as a director you have to grow with
and learn and you know take each project
and each person you know as they come so
not like oh man
I know I I don't I think if you're
micromanaging then then they're looking
at me for all the direction like is this
right is this right is this how you
wanted it and I don't think you know I
want that from an actor I want an actor
to be like that's it and they know they
spoke for the character properly and and
I got what I wanted to and I try to just
put the seed in them and I say hey this
is the this point of the film and uh
this is what the characters feeling and
try to just give them the the linchpins
emotionally to get them to you know
perform and and then that way they can
take their own choices and lead them to
the same place and to me that's the most
organic way to get an actor in a
character to come to life because if
they're actors question questioning
themselves in their mind then those
questions is you you'll see that in the
character and it's not a true commitment
to the character if they're asking
questions because I remember one was
working on the waite I kept messing up
it messing up I thought I was messing up
he just took it to the side to me one
thing
Luda there and then I was a guy cool and
I found myself in the moment after that
just tell me one thing and I'm going
okay so he's pretty good direct that's
all of work so interview you like a drug
that just kind of just kind of just
gives you one little message yeah again
fun fighting when you're fighting you go
to the corner I mean I basically week we
kind of laid we're kind of like like
trained soldiers so you sit down when
you fight and what you see is your
opponent right next to you you don't see
nobody around you don't see the cry you
don't hear nothing oh he has that one
person in your corner which is the guy
that's telling you throw this know that
but you don't look like a trained
soldier so you see oh yeah here is your
coach when he sees your opponent same
thing in films so I like when he talked
to me he talked to me as a fighter like
- he used to box so he even later you
messing up here do this you got to look
after he told me that I might wake up
again and I'm back on the scene so yeah
I don't even say that much stuff I'll
stay stuff like every word that comes
out of your mouth is heavy and then
he'll go back and it will perform again
and I wake up like they're in the way do
something one thing I forgot I forgot
that was it you told me you know it was
wait he's he's basically you know not
necessarily torching there's a woman
tied up you know he's very angry I
racially he's coming off really hard so
in the beginning of the film I want you
to get the feeling of this guys we know
they're torturing this woman he's really
aggressive he has hate real anger for
and I just wasn't feeling it from angel
in the beginning oh my god I'm not
feeling the Hanks or anything like that
and then took a break walk over to him
and I was like listen this woman was
trying to get your kidney we're going to
kidnap your child they were gonna do a
whole bunch of this money said okay now
action and then he came out then he was
retail after that because it I you know
it was literally venom coming out with
every word out of his mouth and that
that's how we saw the character so you
know if anything I should be the guide
you know you talk to speak with your
actors talk when you get you guys all
come up with an idea of how you think
the character should be and express
themselves and then you know I'm the one
on the outside watching and I just help
guide them so what we both think you
know should be
you